recuerdas esa vez en la que snoob dog se
rompió la madre con decenas de otros
raperos fuck bueno Bienvenido a Death
jump Fight For New York este clásico de
culto fue uno de los mejores juegos de
peleas callejeras que existen y para los
que aún lo recuerden Aquí les tengo un
par de detalles del juego uno a medida
que peleabas las heridas se reflejaban
en tu personaje Así que entre más
madreado estés más heridas aparecerán en
todo su rostro dos con tantos raperos y
actores en el juego se nota que se la
pasaron genial ándose diferentes maneras
de romperse los ico Pues a todos ellos
se les dio completa libertad creativa en
sus diálogos y se les dejo crear sus
propios movimientos tres algunas
cinemáticas del juego cambiarán
dependiendo de la consola en la que
estés jugando y cuatro en agosto de 2018
la cuenta oficial de Twitter de Death
Jam publicó esta Misteriosa imagen
tentando a los fans con una posible
secuela que quién sabe si algún día
llegará y tú aún recuerdas esta joya de
los juegos de pelea